our next guest is taking on social media
sometimes negative culture having real
conversations with people who have said
nasty things about him and to him on the
internet his name is dylan maron and he
reaches out to those people who say
those hurtful things and he talks to
them in real life on a podcast called
conversations with people who hate me
the discussions cover a variety of
topics with some people attacking marin
for being gay some saying he's
committing a sin others disagree with
him politically they call him a lot of
names related to that and yet they work
together to forge a connection
any questions that you have for me
no no i think uh
i i don't dislike you i don't like you
you don't dislike me okay i agree on a
lot of stuff we disagree on a lot of
stuff and that's fine that's fine has
this conversation helped you at all
i think so i think so um
just to show that that two people
so ideologically
polarized
can have a good conversation
dylan's out with a new book based on the
podcast it's called conversations with
people who hate me 12 things i learned
from talking to internet strangers it is
published by atria an imprint of simon
schuster which is a division of
paramount which is on planet earth
and we have a human being with us dylan
good morning thank you so much for
having me uh i i love the book i love
the podcast i think it's a wonderful
idea uh though a daunting one you have a
folder called your hate folder i have
the hate folder you know it's still on
my desktop right now oh god so it feels
like a celebrity i wrote about it so
much and it's like there she is there
she is but you're not filling with
things anymore you've learned your list
no this i think this whole project works
as a sort of deterrent you know like
because people are like i don't want to
go on a podcast you know so so i don't
get a lot of hate at me but maybe i'm
incurring it by saying it right now
there's something amazing that happens
when you take a person off of the
internet into a phone call even though
you're not standing in front of each
other just hearing their voice and them
hearing yours makes it harder to be mean
to somebody yeah it's almost impossible
i think you know the internet of course
gamifies a lot of our interactions and
it rewards a lot of negative behavior
because we're a lot of times trying to
entertain our friends our people so
we're jockeying for those likes the gold
coins of the internet and i think the
big difference on the phone is one you
hear their voice they're immediately
human they know you're human too and
there's not an audience for it um you
know yes i'm releasing this as a podcast
but all of these conversations happen in
this really sacred space of the phone
call
this is incredibly brave i just have to
hand it to you because
it's not kind and it's not nice on paper
or on the screen i i don't know how you
overcame
that um that that the fear yeah of
having those conversations how how did
you get over the hurt feelings the
honest answer is that
this grew out of a coping mechanism um
most of these comments and messages i
was receiving on facebook which is i
think an important detail because on
facebook unlike other
uh platforms you can click on someone's
profile and you can learn everything
about them right you are taken you see a
partial resume you see a family tree you
see memes they've shared and you see
this full three-dimensional human and so
i would construct these like backstories
that i would weave for these people and
then talking to them like the
conversation actually to me
feels like the best way to um address
the fear and to take care of the fear
i'm only speaking for myself but what's
your biggest take-home the biggest
lesson
biggest lesson you know there are a lot
um the books just filled with their
how to sell the book here we are um
but i would say you know
so i i naturally empathize with my
guests and this is an inevitability of
talking to someone it's not this saintly
marvel it just happens right when you
speak to someone you know that they're a
human being
and a lot of my guests not all of them
are on the other side of the political
spectrum and sometimes it can feel like
you're doing something wrong by
empathizing with the other and i think
we're living in such divided times that
it becomes scary to empathize with the
other what does this say about me what
am i doing am i doing something wrong
and so i developed a mantra for myself
sort of which is that empathy is not
endorsement right like i can acknowledge
that you are a human being you
hypothetically you not you um you are
also humanizing we're all human but i
can i can acknowledge that the person
i'm speaking to who is so different from
me
that we are that they are a human being
and i can i can feel that and that that
is not co-signing their beliefs right no
by the way lesson seven there are eleven
more you buy the book yeah yeah buy the
book uh uh but you're right empathy is
not endorsement and you can hear how a
person got to that moment of hate yeah
uh and then maybe how they can get out
of it and we all can conversation is a
civic virtue dylan maron thank you very
much conversations with people who hate
me on sale now we'll be right back